no one will outwork me you have to work
hard and smart we have only one way how
do what's that believe nation it's Evan
I believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules that successful
people follow do not be outworked also
if you want to know what tom bill you
dwayne johnson Gary Vee and others have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below there's a gap
between who people are and what they
tell you they want to accomplish my call
time is at 7 then you back your clock up
for hours and then that's when I get up
the reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
[Music]
as Henry Rollins said I don't have
talent so I just get up earlier
the thing that people think about
becoming great about doing the
extraordinary is that it's just meant
for some people and not meant for others
and they spend their time making other
people extraordinary as a way to let
themselves off the hook because if
somebody has just gifted if they were
blessed by God if they were touched by
an angel and then just have something
that you don't and something that you
never will have then it's fine for them
to be great and you to be ordinary but
the reality is it's not how it works
but somehow the cultural narrative has
become one where we celebrate natural
talent that if somebody is graced by God
that if they have something divine about
them that they're somehow better that
it's more beautiful than the scrappy
person who's had to work for everything
they've ever had the guy who simply
acknowledges like Henry Rollins that he
doesn't have more talent than the next
person he's simply willing to help work
them he's willing to set the alarm to
get up to do whatever it takes to find
his path to create that skill to outwork
talent to show that by putting in that
energy and that effort there's a
magnification effective is far greater
than anything that can be given to you
the stowed upon you you have to grab it
you have to take it you have to have a
level of intensity in your life to be
able to leverage it and create something
amazing and as Warren Buffett said
intensity is the price of excellence if
you want to be great
you've got to cultivate that intensity
you've got to understand it's not about
what you were born with it's not about
what you were getting where you started
or even where you're going it is
entirely about what you plant at the
center of your soul how hard you're
willing to go after something how much
focus you're willing to put in your life
and how often you come back to that
level of intensity for who you want to
be because if you want to meet excellent
you will have to pay a price and that
price is eternal vigilance vigilance
over how you spend your time vigilance
over the demands you make of yourself
vigilance over what you allow yourself
to think and believe and when you get to
the point that you only allow yourself
to think and believe things that move
you towards your goals that every day
the actions you take are things that are
designed to get you there and then you
have the intensity to follow that
through to shape yourself to create a
new version of you capable of doing
something extraordinary then your life
is gonna be what you want but not until
then it's never gonna be anything if you
just make other people extraordinary and
say I could never do that
the reality is you could and you're just
not so the thing you have to face right
now
is that it is within your grasp you just
have to go after it
maybe talk about hard work all the time
mistake you know
man if you had to get up every single
morning remind yourself how hard you
need to work your I need to choose a
different profession you know because
that shouldn't be there is that I wake
up in the morning excited to get to it
you know if I'm not training I'm missing
it I'm not watching the game of bass I
miss it you know there's no place I'd
rather be
and if you have that feeling then you're
truly doing what God has put you on this
earth to do I feel like for me it feels
seamless because you're prepared for so
long but it's just like you guys
prepping for a game that's the fun part
that's where sigh it's fun and people
are paying their hard-earned dollars to
come see you they're cheering they're
going bananas they're booing it out of
you on the road
it's that's fun that's what you live for
I mean that's the juice right there the
prep is where the character is made and
I just don't mean the character I play I
mean the character in here so for me the
prep is getting with the director
getting with the producers getting with
the writers getting with the getting
with the so in essence it's like getting
with all your coaches and your different
position coaches and and all the
meetings that you have to have right so
that's the work you put in the key for
me was where does it start
what's the anchor what's the anchor so I
could have all these ambitions and you
guys have all these ambitions which is
great it's important I'll play this role
you'll play that role I'll execute this
thing and it'll come out this summer
you guys will execute this thing during
the summer right what it's time to
really put in a lot more work but the
key with me is just always finding what
the anchor is and the anchor is getting
up at 4 o'clock in the morning every day
before anybody else and grounding my
thought process is in the no one will
outwork me no one I love and I respect
you guys one that work me
I'll start with this two hands putting
it'll work how much time you spent a
month you said those four things how
much time do you actually spend on it in
a day zero
sometimes I assume in a week how much do
you spend two hours great now is the
most important part of this meeting how
many hours do you sleep at night
great so I love the way you said it I
have to have seven so if I wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me Gary I have to
have seven right now let's go somewhere
else I have to know what you're doing
the other 17 hours I would bet the house
that we can find an hour every day I
guarantee it because you might be
working all 17 hours but you might not
be working on something smarter than
spending an hour a day on the thing that
you're talking about do you understand
that's I mean look that's the answer the
answer is time you know people talk
about working hard and working smart the
answer is only both
you have to work hard and smart based on
your ambition if you want to build a
business for yourself that is like a 1%
life most people understand what
building a business for yourself is it's
very special it's very special trying to
build a business for yourself
everybody's doing now pulling it off
trying to play basketball everybody can
try being an NBA player trying to be a
rapper or a singer everybody's doing
pulling it off trying to be a footballer
an actress got it so you're trying great
pulling it off is hard it takes
everything time and smarts you need
seven I'm glad you said it that way
because this makes this piece of content
more valuable
it's the 17 other Alice
I'll give you an example a lot of people
drive to work for 45 minutes if they
took a bus for an hour and 15 minutes
they would save money and get more work
done
but do you have the humility to take the
bus for driving your car I feel I have
energy I feel I have to improve
something and that's why we come here
we sent a nice message each other hey
let's go tomorrow 3:00 p.m. we have the
train we have to Train everybody and
some people say I'm tired today is
Sunday today is the rest day but some
people say ok we're gonna come because
we have somebody have fight after one
month somebody a fight after one and a
half month and you know that's why
everybody we have to train if you have
fight please come to come Jimmy train
and only hard work you know we have only
one way it's like you cut away
I remember who all the time come from
here running and sprint here ten time
and go back to running it's take like
maybe twenty five thirty minute every
day before I go to school I do this
training running here
sprint to this mountain and go back home
drills home resting drills little bit
lifting and go to the school
it's my like every day I do this every
day and all the time when I come to
village I turn here all the time come
here running around Tama do sprints
fight expect expect to be uncomfortable
and if you're not devoting between eight
and twelve hours a day on your craft
then you're not really trying to be a
professional like you got to realize you
trying to be competitive being a
professional means being the best in the
world that doesn't just come with skill
that comes with discipline you know that
means you have to have a certain kind of
work ethic that means you're doing
things that most won't people really
don't understand that like they think
they got skill so everything is going to
come to them skill is that actually like
a curse I've seen people with no skill
that realize that and understand that
they have to work hard to get this skill
worked so hard that they do better than
the people that have skill and that are
arrogant and entitled that feel that
it's just come to them and then they
just become a waste you know having
potential is [ __ ] if you don't
realize it it becomes corny like you're
the cool guy when you have potential but
like ten years later if you don't
realize that they need a corny guy you
know I'm saying and I never want to ever
be that guy my mom gives really good
advice she said you know when you start
working you better be the most
hard-working nicest person in the room
because if you're not then there's
always gonna be someone prettier nicer
and more hard-working it's always a
first impression I think that that's the
thing I most Lee just try and remember
is that you have to give your energy for
that time because it's the time that
counts and that's how the person is
gonna remember you
point number eight you will be
hospitalized for burnout or hard work
multiple times Marya knows it's watching
this from you know behind the cameras
this has happened to me multiple times
one time we're in Jacksonville and I'm
giving this talk in Jacksonville and
I'm speaking my legs are wobbly it looks
like I'm about to pass out the room is
full it is hot it's summertime we finish
I walk out I'm walking in the parking
lot with Paul all of a sudden I collapse
I tell Paul take me to the emergency
room we get in the RV I go to the
emergency room they set me up with IVs I
say doc what's going on with me since
you're just exhausted they gave me two
IVs I was fired up we got in the RV
drove down to Miami stayed up to three
four five o'clock in the morning did it
again the next day why cuz that's the
stuff you're gonna do a few times when
you push the envelope it's just gonna be
happening now by the way some parents
will watch this and say I can't believe
you my kids are watching you telling my
kid admires you how dare you see this
kind of stuff to my kids ma'am sir let
me simplify something for you the
chances of your kid even doing this is
less than 1% because the person who's
going to do this is already thinking
about this stuff they just want some
direction I want to know when they face
off a glide so don't worry about your
kid there's one percent chance that your
kids even gonna want to step up to
something like this any other format
that means like as a person to person
you know I'm not better than you we're
all equal people but when it comes to
this music I'm the best I'm better than
everybody I'm not here to contend with
nobody I don't see competition
here to be the best and biggest that's
it anybody who stands in the way of me
getting to being the best for the days
will shut them down musically like come
toe to toe with me even it's not that
I'm in my head and I believe that I'm
just the best it's to work anything it's
the time it's the grind work that I go
that I put in if they blocked me out of
session and I'm blocked out for sessions
and I'm blocked out from the 15th to the
18th I'm sleeping in the studio so I
wake up and I'm going to record again
because you're not gonna beat me and
work at it you're not going to be
consistent you're not gonna be I'm
working pretty hard and so there are a
lot of people but I'm one of them my
car's there pretty early and it's in the
parking lot pretty late and on weekends
so and I value my family time a lot so I
I'm pretty committed to this and seeing
Apple turn around the company I mean
it's I started the company with Steve
Wozniak in my parent's garage you know
20 years ago and over 22 years ago and
so there's a definite place in my heart
for this I'm drawing a salary if I think
$1 per year so I hope I'm not burdening
the shareholders too much and and I'm I
very much want to see Apple could turned
around and I think it's gonna so I don't
know how much more committed I could be
if people need these symbols well maybe
that'll happen I don't know but but you
know my answer to them is I don't know
how I could be working any harder and
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Casey nice tat on how to hustle
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what do
you want to be among the best in the
world at number two how will you make
time every single day to get better and
number three what will you eliminate
from your schedule so you can focus
[Music]
there have been a lot of questions
especially after we posted episode 1
about workflow right about how the edits
happen and how we work together so it
kinda goes like this when I did the vlog
I would shoot all day and all night post
the next morning that worked for 3 6 8
though I shoot all day I edit all night
and then the next morning instead of
posting I give that edit to Dan and that
edit is like an incomplete edit to story
it so at that point in time the
narrative is together but all the other
stuff like all the other stuff like
color correction or sound design all
that takes so much time and then the
next day we post so it's like on a
Monday if we shoot out in one day we
post that video on Wednesday instead of
on Tuesday and then we attempt to edit
pass now this is all theory and we've
only done to edit so far and it's
already complicated like it seems so
easy by giving us that extra time but we
haven't slept in four days yeah
come to New York Casey see it would be
fun the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon if
you want to know what is stopping you
from success check out the video right
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there dr. Wayne Dyer houses as the
famous phrase where it's not oh I'll
believe it when I see it it's like I'll
see it when I believe it